as the fast franchise hurdles toward the
Finish Line not every driver who starred
in the franchise has stayed in the race
so what happened to the actress who
played Suki In Too Fast Too Furious
anyway looking back on The Fast and
Furious franchise Too Fast Too Furious
set the tone for what was coming the Vin
Diesel less sequel saw Brian taking down
an Argentinian drug lord with a race car
something that the modern fast movies
are all too familiar with it also
introduced a few franchise veterans with
Roman and tej joining the series tsuki
played by Devon Aoki also played a
memorable role in 2 Fast 2 Furious only
to disappear from the franchise Without
a Trace Devine Aoki is best known as a
model finding massive success in the
industry before hitting adulthood
however in the early 2000s Aoki decided
to test out the movie industry appearing
in a few films before 2010 besides 2
Fast 2 Furious she appeared in movies
like Sin City d-e-b-s and the infamous
Dead or Alive however in 2009 she
retired from acting to focus on raising
her kids which might explain why she's
never returned turned to The Fast and
Furious franchise since then she's only
appeared in two documentaries with one
of them I'll sleep when I'm dead
focusing on her half-brother DJ Steve
Aoki in recent years however Aoki has
returned to the fashion industry which
leads us to ask could we see her return
to Fast and Furious the franchise has
brought back old characters time and
time again so it's arguably about time
Suki returns all right ladies we're good
fast X is the beginning of the end for
the Fast and Furious franchise so time's
running out for aokisuki to return in
the main series if she ever does the
next installments will likely celebrate
the entire Series so the more characters
that come back the better a spin-off may
be the next best option if fans don't
get Sookie back in time for the
franchise's conclusion in a 2022
interview Universal Pictures chairwoman
Donna Langley told Business Insider I
would love to see a female fast so would
Vin Diesel we have so many great and
amazing female characters in our
franchise and now there's the new
edition of Brie Larson to add to the
incredible roster I would love to see us
do a female fast if that's the case what
better female character to include than
Suki 2 Fast 2 Furious introduces her as
the leader of an all-female street
racing crew and she shows that she has
what it takes to race against anybody if
Universal plans to do a female fast
movie Suki could be in it assuming that
Aoki is willing to return to the screen
pairing her with some of the other women
of the franchise sounds like a recipe
for Success it's not impossible Devin
Aoki appears to have retired from
regular acting for now but she has
graced a few music videos since she
stopped appearing in movies and TV shows
on a regular basis in 2013 she had a
cameo in the video for the killer single
just another girl which shows her
hanging out in a makeshift theater
watching a black and white film on the
screen elsewhere Aoki was one of a
number of celebrities who appeared in
the video for Fergie's track MILF money
in this one the model joined a slew of
other celebrities to portray a group of
moms in a bubble gum-esque Suburban
neighborhood Aoki shows up in a few
scenes rocking fancy outfits and hanging
out with Fergie's star-studded Entourage
the most recent music video Aoki starred
in was for Steve Aoki and bts's wasted
on me collaboration the video sees her
out on a date with a member of BTS and
she also gets to mime some of the song's
lyrics into a microphone throughout the
video of course a few music videos and
documentary appearances don't
necessarily imply that Aoki is dying to
return to the now massive franchise she
once made a small appearance in but if
the franchise does want to dig deep into
its history again the records have shown
that it's hard to say no when Vin Diesel
comes calling
[Music]